Stallone and swartz Nagar are starring
in a movie together a concept that was
relevant 20 years ago yeah it's not like
we've been asking for it for 20 years we
were asking for it 20 years ago there's
difference escape plan so escape plan
stars sylvester stallone he has the most
interesting career of anyone I've ever
heard of he goes into prison voluntarily
and then breaks out to prove hey that
prison is not actually failsafe so
someone comes to Salone and they're like
hey we have this really super secret
off-the-book prison we need you to go in
there and prove that no one can break
out it before we really start sending
scumbags in there so Stallone for some
odd reasons like we do we stood and now
no one knows where this prison is
Stallone's in there and he meets Fortson
eager and together they're like yeah
we're gonna break out of here because
Stallone's like I was set up
this place is shitty and together they
come up with an escape plan now I'm
telling you this movie sounds like a
good idea 20 years ago
I grew up loving Stallone and swartz
Nagar and they're still great and I've
wanted to see them in a movie together
and now I do I mean we got Expendables
too but this one they're like the only
ones you concentrate on and now you get
it and you're like all right because
this movie is okay the biggest thing
this movie has going against it in my
opinion is the concept of the present in
the beginning of the movie you see
Stallone in this normal maximum-security
prison and it's interesting in it's cool
and you see him break out you're like
that's awesome then they go to this
crazy comic-book cartoon fantasy prison
where everything is just extreme they're
in these glass boxes and you're like
that's just not real tell me Guantanamo
Bay looks or looked like that it does
all the guards are wearing these ominous
black masks kind of reminded me of the
movie face off you know the Nicolas Cage
John Travolta movie my least favorite
thing in that entire movie is the
concept of that prison where they have
magnetic boots and you're like this
isn't even a real prison it was cool
scene Stallone build his plan yeah but
there was no tension in it it's not like
he was going head to head it an
intellectual game with the warden I did
like Jim Caviezel as the warden anytime
you see Jesus being an you're
like oh that's something but he was such
an over-the-top villain you can tell the
director was like we just need someone
to be an extreme you be an
extreme oh you're
trick that's awesome that's how douche
bags are crazy eccentric in that
introverted kind of way you're like
Hannibal Lecter's dudes like sowing
moths and he's like you filmed me for
the last time but then he'll have really
eccentric manner isms it was an
interesting enough character for our
comic book just like the prison I mean
really if I wanted to see a Prison Break
movie I would like to see a prequel to
the rock where it shows Sean Connery's
character breaking out of Alcatraz that
would have been awesome the thing that
sells escape plan is the gimmick that
Swartz and Stallone are in a movie
together
you take that out what do you have you
have a great be Prison Break movie with
a prison that's unbelievable with a
warden that's introverted and eccentric
for the sake of being a douche bag
warden and a plot that tries to be more
clever than it is because it has all
these twists and turns that aren't
really twists and turns because you just
don't care about any of them then it
wraps up so quickly in the end you're
like what was the point of those twists
and turns I'm saying is when you look
past the gimmick of swartz Nagar and
Stallone being in a movie together have
a movie that you see for what it is a
movie that's probably cool if you're
drunk yeah now it's a potty you play
like did you put it look good you know
would have helped in this movie
subtitles what were you doing before you
live here I was out I was governor I was
banging the maid and I ruined the state
forget prison food right just saying
that they would have helped all right so
your favorite Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie and Stallone movie we're doing - I
would say least favorite but we know
what the least favorite Arnold moves
gonna be we just know - whatever your
favorite to be comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you